the fourth and final final day of the
Simon's workshop I see the fourth and
final day of the Simon's workshop on
quantum protocols so in the past two
days we've heard a lot about how
non-local games and multi proofer
interactive proofs can test really
powerful quantum systems in particular
provers with unbounded number of qubits
and we also saw how those protocols have
really important and significant
consequences for questions and
complexity theory in mathematics so
today we come back to much more
immediate concerns and we're gonna focus
on how to verify and test real-world
quantum computers so we'll hear about
protocols for cross-checking quantum
platforms against each other and how to
benchmark quantum systems and we'll also
learn about different noise models for
quantum systems as well so let me remind
you all that you are very much
encouraged to ask questions throughout
the talk you can do that by typing in a
question to the question-and-answer box
or you can click on the raise your hand
question and I can unmute you so you can
ask the question yourself so please do
participate throughout so our first talk
of the day will be given by andreas
Alban from the Austrian Academy of
Sciences and he's going to tell us about
cross-platform verification so undress
thanks very much for the introduction
and the invitation to speak here and
yeah I would like to thank the
organizers in particular very much for
putting this great workshop together
this fight was very difficult at the
moment so I'm very happy to talk today
about some reasons we're fortunate in
Innsbruck on something which we called
cross but from verification of
intermediate scale quantum devices with
a technique which without randomized
measurements so as already said I will
speak about for this talk about very
concrete protocols and on to physically
test and verify in this sense an
intermediate scale quantum devices so
misc devices and these protocols will be
in certain sense directly tuned to the
particular strengths and weaknesses of
this current state of the art a quantum
devices in particular I would speak
about a verification protocol in the
sense of the comparative verification or
a cross-checking of quantum devices by
means of comparing can compare comparing
two or multiple of them the outcome of
quantum simulations or quantum computing
computations performed on them and this
comparison should be done in a full
quantum level and this to achieve this
we use technically we call randomized
measurements here it's something we have
been developing in Innsbruck over the
past years quite intensively and give a
bunch of a lot of people involved
particularly my supervisor pitted solar
a former postdoc in a group anavar and
also vacant Christian another show floor
network quite some experimental results
which have been obtained in a very nice
collaboration we have had it Cokie in
Innsbruck and with a local iron wrapping
group that is led by Anna blood and in
Christian rolls so as I've said I will
be speaking about verification of the
intermediate scale devices so I would
like to start with just flashing one
slide and what kind of devices I have
actually in mind here and young young
pretty broad so I'm considering all
sorts of nice nice devices which are in
today's laboratories for example
ultracold atoms forgettings
and which can be trapped in in optical
lattices or optical tweezers and you
could can do very nice quantum
simulation experiments of them also some
building blocks of quantum computation
have had been demonstrated in
particularly flipper buttons when we of
course also trapped ions which can serve
as full-fledged quantum quantum
computers but can you also use them to
perform quantum simulations of spin
mornings in same holds basically true
for a superconducting qubits and many
more of these platforms which are
currently emerging and
developed more and more come to all of
these nice devices I think great toolbox
which have extra mentalists have been
developing in the course of the last
years which includes a single side or
single particle resolved quantum control
and measurement in these devices and so
given this toolbox and the fact that all
of these systems become bigger and
bigger and less more and more complex
there's also the intermediate question
about how to verify such devices so to
test that array they perform as they
would like and the functionality is
essentially correct and then also to
probe the interesting quantum state
which you can and and prepare in them
and so in my talk I would like to
propose a presently one one kind of
possible protocol to answer such
question and how I approach this kind of
things in basically all of these and
quantum systems here and so to start
with I would like to to to show you what
to remind you just in review in one side
and a kind of furious sketch on how
quantum experiments I actually done
today and later on I will just
generalize this men to a specific mo
protocol to specific protocols so and a
typical quantum experiment is done in
the following way you start with a very
simple classical initial state which can
be easily prepared to be a product state
let's say this for ions here which was
prepared in some spin up state and then
actually the interesting part starts to
happen so you from a quantum simulation
or quantum computation and when this is
done there has been hopefully an
interesting many-body quantum state has
been prepared and you would like to go
out and learn something about this
quantum state now and the way this is
typically done is when weight one just
performs a projective measurement of for
example a local spin configuration in
the system
of course from from a single such
projected measurements you don't learn
much due to the inherent probabilistic
nature of quantum mechanics but what you
what's typically been done is it's just
the measurement is repeated a lot of
times to learn quantum expectation
values for example here just a
probabilities to see such specific spin
configuration and from this quantum
expectation values you can then and
learn in turn learn something about the
quantum state which we have prepared in
the first place so that's kind of a
basic scheme for most experiments are
done today and it's of course very
successful and applied in on a
day-to-day basis what I would like to do
now in this talk is to generalize in a
in a specific way anything if you have
listened to the great talk by richard
kuhn and on monday in this workshop
humid or really be a bit familiar with
what's coming next
so the entire sequence so the first
building block of physique and stays the
same the quantum state is prepared but
then prior to the projective measurement
we inject a controlled random unitary
control the random operation onto the
system and then perform a projective
measurement then you get some outcome
and typically what you could not do is
starting to repeat this again a lot of
times and you will find again a quantum
expectation value but this content
expectation that it does not know not
only depend on this tape side that you
have prepared but also on the random
unitary which is applied here so it's
itself this quantum expectation value is
now itself probabilistic it's a random
it's a single instance of a random
variable and this single incident
doesn't tell you much it's just a random
number however it becomes interesting if
you start studying the distribution of
such quantum expectation values over
many random unit Ares and what we have
learnt in the past years is that these
kind of distributions of such
expectation values contain really a lot
of interesting physics so for example if
you just go and and look at second-order
here so you just multiply two of these
expectation where those probabilities
together and take an average
over many random unit Ares may have been
found with basically quantities of this
type and contained a lot of interesting
physics so you can use them to broke at
any entropies in entanglement of the
quantum state you I've been preparing
here you can use if you perform such
kind of protocols on two independent
devices you can you can use this tool to
measure many body fidelity's and it's an
intern to use to do such kind of
prospered from verification this will be
the main talk of my talk today here but
then you can also use this type of
statistics which type of protocols to
access more quantum simulation inspired
quantities for example one can measure
out of time ordered correlation
functions and also use this type of
statistics even to fully characterize
and many-body topological invariants in
symmetry protected topological phases so
you can really this kind of statistics
can serve as a complete can completely
classify one dimensional spt phases so
it's a it's a five powerful toolbox in a
quite quite nice tool and in especially
in this workshop and not the only one
about talking about this kind of a
similar setting so we had had already on
on Monday at work by Richard Cohen who
introduced this notion of classical
shadows which is which he even showed
that decision in can be served as an
optimal way to estimate expectation
values as observers
and just in the next talk after me I
think we will hear some we have a talk
by joseph Emerson on randomized and
cyclic benchmarking has also used such
kind of random random military
operations to extract noise properties
in quantum of quantum operations but not
today in in in my talk I will focus on
these three aspects I will first
introduce this randomized measurements
in a bit more direct a bit more a deeper
way in on the example of a second
trainee entropy
another country's main topographic store
which is cross verification
cross-platform verification and in the
end if time permits I will show you also
some some results and which have been
recently obtained first enough of a
protocol to measure its out of time
autocorrelation functions with the same
with the same toolbox with randomized
measurements and this have been
developing this particular also with
norman yahoo from from berkeley and i
will show you in all of these few blocks
and it basically show us some
experimental results from the
collaboration with journals and andreas
have a quick question yes long so in the
previous slide it looks like for the
these correlations you have the choice
of like this s1 and s2 so for you have
different applications is it you're just
picking different ensembles of unit
aries you and also different choices of
s1 and s2 or so yes you can pick
different ensembles you can pick and
different as one or typically you can
also sum over different ones i will show
in the next slide it in more detail what
exactly
okay exactly so it will appear here in
because of this purity measurements
again and I stand here so I would like
to show this this protocol which is a in
first and pretty independent of any
device very particular implemented but I
would like to show it here now and for
the purpose of this talk directly in the
experimental setting base has been
realized so and what they have in mind
wrapping group in Innsbruck is that they
have such portraits they trap linear
strings of ions and then they can do
exactly in this in the quantum
simulation kind of mode of the
experiment what they can do is then
exactly what I've been describing before
there so they start with some simple
product state and then they can do time
evolution if an interactive anybody
amazonian that's typically a long range
XY or eating type model and then they've
prepared some many-body states i and an
hour task or our question was how can be
characterized now the entanglement that
has actually been hopefully built up
during this time evolution so how can
you characterize the intrinsic want
properties which which happening in in
in this cause of his time evolution due
to the interaction in san antonio and
the idea was we can use that we can at
this point quantify the bipartite
entanglement using the purities
securities of individual subsystem in
and then also of the total system and
conclude from this of the first of the
unitarity of the dynamics in the main
also of the entanglement the problem
here is of course that this purity is
not a single copy observable and in such
an iron trapping experiment you have
typically only a single copy of your
quantum state at hand at one time so the
questions how to measure in best
precisely Davis when demise measurements
come in in in the following way so here
prior the condom state is prepared and
then you apply a set of local random
unitary in this case local one so in
this
as it's just each each cubed each spin
is individually rotated on its Bloch
sphere on a completely random way
so specifically is this unit area picked
from from unitary two designs here
button since it's just single qubit you
can also send it directly from Bihar
measure and then you after this
application of this this random
military's you perform a measurement in
the fixed computational basis and then
one measures by repetition with a fixed
unitary estimates probabilities of
seeing such spin configurations and now
this has been repeated in the second
round for many unit Ares and you would
like to characterize the statistics of
these these probabilities and so the
first and most trivial thing is just you
take an average over these probabilities
and of course that what you find when if
the experiment is working correctly in
the sense that you you that you have
that we each it's been each
configuration is now equally likely so
it should be just one divided by the
hilbert space dimension beat the average
that's just a first indication that you
have indeed prepared a random state but
of course it's it's it's just really a
third indication and some sort of also
trivial but it becomes more interesting
if you know it really started exactly
autocorrelation start looking at
second-order correlations so for example
you you just take these probabilities
multiply two of them together take an
average over many many militaries and
then you sum them up there's some
coefficients in front sum all of them up
and what you find is that this equals in
the average of a many random unitary
Svend directly to the purity here so
second-order cross correlations gives
rise to a second order quantity here is
reduced and the purity of is reduced
density matrix so typically the
experiment is done on the full system
but then by a post-processing you
underst restrict to individual
subsystems here whatever whatever you
like and then you get purities of all
possible subsystems missus
so that's also kind of here it's it it
doesn't really matter which so in the
end it doesn't matter what kind of
specific spin configuration you pick
here because you you take an average of
a manual and unitary so you've you
render you in the end you get something
which is invariant and the local unitary
transformations out here so it doesn't
really pick but ie
since you get the information of all all
probabilities from these measurements
from these local local measurements as
David Cross was telling them we can
relieve some overall of thank you and
that's that's how it is done here just
let me now show you in one slide how one
can could just prove such such relation
here and the first and sort of direct
observation is and that the purity is of
course it's not an expectation value of
a single copy observe but it's an
expectation that over to copy observer
and the observer so quad swap operating
so that kind of the first thing to see
the second thing is that of course if I
what I can do is if I have such a
product of expectation values of
probabilities and and some some here in
front I can always rewrite this as a big
trace over in some sense artificially or
butt-to-butt
but you can called virtual copies of his
to office discontent state and the
operator which is appearing in front
here is basically given by this to copy
operator a which is justified by this
coefficients here in front world with
this random unitary office in the form
of this tensor product here and that's
probably familiar to many in the
audience that's better better unitary
it's willing channel in this case
evaluated on this to copy space on this
to copy operator and one can just
calculate what comes out here this one
uses here also something that you have
heard on Monday already several times
one can use through a while duality to
evaluate this channel and what one finds
is that actually and the channel up
lightens operator a will be just a
linear combination
of permutation operators and none of
this perturbation operator permutation
operators this has cost directly the
swap operator and so the goal is we
would like to find an operator a [ __ ]
such that this is a whole linear
combination here collapses just to the
swap operator and you can find this and
choose particular with coefficients
which have been shown here in the slide
before so what's actually done in in
this formula is really that we we sample
a sample here from from the matrix
element of this pop operators by these
various unitary transformations so this
all what I want want to say to the proof
if you if you look at a bit if you look
at this a little bit more
experimentalist point of view and you
will find that the protocol is actually
it has its strengths it's only it has
only local operations and local
measurements so something which and it's
only a single copy so it's something
which David Rose would call local local
and measurements and local local
operations and this is in particular to
be seen in Qantas to to earlier previous
experiments and protocols which were
based on the interference of two copies
so another way of measuring the purity
would really be directly preparing two
copies of your quantum state in your lab
and this has been done in very nice
experiments in optical lattices and then
measure the swap operated by an
interference of these two copies so this
is possible but it's from any
experiments for example loss for this
time trapping experiment here it's a
difficult task to do because you need to
do you need to prepare two copies and
off your stake at the same time in the
same lab so this protocol uses only
these local operations on a single when
a single copy in this sends a bit easier
or if it comes also its drawback that
you to pair you need to do a lot of
measurements so you look at statistics
of its probability
you averaged them over many unit Ares so
what one finds even analyzes the number
of measurements one in school one finds
two became exponential we're off here of
the necessary number of measurements the
four subsystems I bought an interesting
so the global system can be very big but
the subsystem dummy and determines the
number of measurements you need to do
but sort of importantly is that this
exponential is is if you at least if you
compare it to a full quantum state
tomography
it's a very friendly and exponential as
you say so you can go up to maybe 10 or
20 cubits even if this kind of protocols
and estimate purity is a reasonable
number of measurements and unit Ares
yeah I would like to also connect to
this network by by Richard is also shown
that his classical shadows and you can
kind of see can also access a purities
for example in there you it was also
finding this exponential growth so I
think it's something pretty fundamental
if you have if you don't assume anything
about your content state here and would
like to measure the choice but to show
you that despite with this exponential
we can actually this can actually be
done in the experiment in a reasonable
way I would like to show you know some
some experimental results of exactly
this type of experiments of you have a
10 iron system and would like to measure
purities of individual subsystems so
what's what's plotted here is a purity a
purity as a function of subsystem size
so number one would be just the iron 1/2
would behind 1 and 2/3 would behind 1 2
and 3 and so on up to 10 which would be
the full system and so what you see here
is the purity of the initial state of
this experiment so this is a nude state
it should be a pure product state
ideally right and you also see that okay
single qubit is quite pure but then they
measured purity drops a little bit up to
still 4/10 iron system are quite high
value of point seven six you know and in
addition one understands quite well
where this comes
this drop it's really the coherence
which acts as its initial state it's
dead preparation and it's the Koreans
which acts during the application of
this signature bit random units okay so
you have here this kind of drop but if
you know if you now start time evolution
what one sees is that the purities of
individuals individual subsystems small
substance become quickly very mixed and
they drop even further and but when the
purity increases again and the total
subsystem purity is over time evolution
approximately at least within aerobars
constant in time so this means that this
in aero bars one when performs here
really kind of unitary dynamics in the
system and in addition individual
subsystems become quickly better mix and
if you look at it you can also look at
this in a dual picture of course just
that's just the same data shown as a
shown yeah as a negative logarithm so
the second grainy entropy and what you
see here is that you have a lot of
entropy and in the smaller subsystems
and you have not so much entropy in the
global system and this clearly shows you
various entanglement and build up in the
system and you see this is kind of nice
and decay of entropy with increasing
subsystem size which is something that
can only happen in frontal systems so
this is yeah it's first demonstrates
which ways bipartite entanglement in the
system and you as I've said already
before and if it's method you can even
you can go a little bit further and you
you can look at all possible subsystems
and not only connected ones like like
plotted here but also disconnected
subsystems and so in total there are two
to be ten subsystems in this ten iron
system and so what you have is it what's
plotted here is two to attend subsystem
is a function of its size and you see
that all possible subsystems I actually
have a higher entropy and the global
system here so what this tells you is
that all by partitions in this in this
systems are really anything
exactly so what this is all what I
wanted to say to this this purity
estimation and now I would like to come
to the second part but before I would
like yeah if they're asked where are
some questions at the moment
because you go back to the
the grass yes I I didn't fully
understand what's the difference between
the horizontal axis and the vertical
axis save the left yeah yeah so that's
the purity of in a subsystem so it can
be between 1 and 0 of identity matrix
and what's plotted here is the number of
qubits like side of this of a subsystem
of which the density so the Securities
of reduced density matrices of certain
subsystems and the number of qubits in
in the subsystems is padded here so one
would be adjust the in-1 the reduced
density the purity of the reduced
density matrix of iron 1 and then you
have fine 1 and 2 and so on up to 9 10
would be the density the purity of
identity matrix of the entire system the
purple line is for all 10 from the gap
line purple line is this would behind 1
2 and this would behind 1 and 2 and this
would be the full 10 iron system at a
time which is T zero so this is his
quench dynamics experiment but what's
done here is you start with a simple
initial state and this is our purities
of these initial stages various
subsystems and then the different colors
are different at time of the quench
dynamics so at the moment at the
beginning what you expect is that you
have a pure product state but of course
in experiment it's not quite pure you
what what you see is that a single iron
is it's not entangled before the other
so it's purity is this one if you reduce
look at the reduced subsystem of reduced
density matrix of online you see just is
approximately 1 so you it's a pure state
and then it's but it's not quite 1 its
0.99 and when you go to 0.99 to the
power of 10 approximately it's not quite
a number but something like this you see
that and you find here drop
and that up to the food system I see so
the color the colored lines correspond
to some computation or some dynamics
exactly so in in this experiment and
what's done here is they prepare a
simple initial state and then they do
time evolution this is interacting
anybody Hamiltonian and and what's
plotted here is exactly the time is
after certain times you stop time
evolution and look at the purity the
purity the distribution of various
subsystems and so this would be I this
would be the initial time so there's no
time evolution so it's just a supposedly
pure products it's not quite pure but we
understand those and why and then you
start increasing time evolution so we
let time evolution or Bailey time
evolution in the lab they let drank from
one one millisecond and then again we
stop and look at the purity of various
subsystems access I is the size of a the
set exactly like here is 1 is to 2 ions
and so on yes exactly and then it's
precisely like this you you see that
over in the course of the time evolution
so longer the time evolution goes we
find that individual subsystems are more
and more mixed smaller ones there's the
total system purity space with constant
in over this time evolution okay and we
also have a question here from one
thanks to in the expression for the
purity so you have two averages right
like so one would be over s and si and
then another one over you so like in
when you do it in experiment do you go
more on averaging over different s or do
you have to do a lot of different use
and so on
so which one dominates and I like they
so basically the the s is not it's not a
problem because what what's done in in
the experiment is they measure you know
each
on each qubit we measure in the
computational basis and if you just now
record you get you get one shot you get
one configuration out and then you
repeat this a lot of times for a fixed
otherwise sequence and you get just by
counting statistics you get just the
probability of all possible as for all
possible basis States I see you've all
of them you get probabilities of all of
them exactly by just repeating this
fixed sequence with a fixed set of
unitary is here a lot of times you get
accounting just by counting you get
statistics you can estimate the
probability of seeing a specific
configuration and that's typically
that's one thing which is done it's one
loop and then the second loop is your
average over many unitary and then you
your average all efficient but as you
said there's a lot of averaging going on
so for example in practice what one does
is this this sequence to estimate is
these probabilities is just repeatedly
of the order of 100 times in a Hilbert
space of 1000 so we a lot of times don't
see a single spin configuration at all
but so the estimation of probabilities
is very bad in a sense but then the
average over the counter for all of them
and then the average of a many random
integer is here and in this way you get
in the end a good approximation of this
period okay thanks
okay then I move on and and come to the
second part and you know I'm facing now
facing the following situation so we
have to quantum machine suppose we have
two of them
and they prepare some quantum many-body
steps I and you would like what you
would like to do is to verify that they
have both prepared the same stage so
imagine this could be the outcome of
some quantum simulation or quantum
computation we would just want to know
whether base both of them have done the
same this can be in a very broad sense
like it can be super it can be quantum
computing kind of simulation platforms
also different different ones in
particular different ones and you would
like just to test whether they form in a
consistent way and of course if these
machines operate in a way their bacon
and they they can look at also a theory
or we can you can do a classical
simulation of the computation of the
simulation and we would also like to
compare with a known fury state which
and know this quantum state on my
classical machine they say matches to
the quantum for the second part where
there exist already protocols at
constant time and which have been
developed by Steve which I think we'll
be talking just later so in in this talk
I will concentrate more on this side
that we have at the moment we have
utterly no knowledge about this quantum
state and prepared in these machines and
we just would like to check whether
every same so they can be unknown but he
would like to know whether they are the
same and what what does it mean to be
the same so we would like to measure the
fidelity between these two quantum
states prepared here and for pure States
it would be just fidelity would be just
the overlap of the two quantum states
squared and but typically an experiment
of course we don't have pure States what
we would like to look at is for example
we have a globally mixed States of an
entire system or we could also just
start looking and comparing subsystems
of entangled States so can be subsystems
are very large
like very large font and devices and we
just look and compare and certain
subsystems here and then of course we
need mix that fidelities and this is not
then there's not a unique fidelity
anymore
the couple of on the most canonical is
maybe they're the women fidelity which
is however to do it's complicated like
it square root structure it's
complicated 2x success I think
numerically and and even more for
experiments so somewhat simpler
quantities which are also fidelity's are
the so-called here which mid fidelity's
that which are bit are following
structure so one of them is just here
just what you do is you you have here a
trace product of two of the two and
density matrices and that's itself it's
not a fidelity because even if these two
density matrix are exactly the same if
you mixed when of course this trace
product is not one but what you can do
is you can renormalize this by the
maximum for example by the maximum of
these two purities and when one finds
that this is whole expression is indeed
a fidelity it fulfills certain actions
and it can also be at least conjectured
that ways and a relation to where to the
human fidelity at least on average over
many quantum states so this is kind of
the type of quantity I'm looking at in
these asking the questions how can the
measure is in quantum many-body systems
and of course they're yes just a quick
this is Robin Bloom code very quick
question um why are these the questions
that you want to answer why do you want
to verify that the two machines have
prepared the same state why is the
fidelity the right metric and why are
the subsystem fidelity's interesting it
seems like that's sort of foundational
and you know we we could phrase the
questions in many different ways yes
exactly and so what our intention was so
is yeah it's it's really basically
motivated from an experimental setting
we have to quantum machines very they
don't really
they might even be not accessible
anymore by direct classical computation
and you would like to check whether they
perform in a consistent way and then our
idea was just can be checked whether
they have to prepare to set they run
some computation or some simulations can
be based in a very different physical
architecture but when you would like to
check whether they done this in the same
way if we come to the same outcome and
and how are you imagining this here is
just looking at the overlap of just
looking at the quantum state if you
preparing and and check whether they're
in the same and in this way at least
gain trust of the two devices and maybe
you have more confidence in one of those
devices because you have tested it a lot
and then you just cross track your
segment machine which you have also a
hand on newly building and you just
cross check does it prepare does it
prepare the same quantum state and
therefore level and and to do this we
imagine that for fidelity is a good
measure because it just says we yeah it
is the same quantum state and to what
degree it is the same quantum state it
is one no ID case from born and this is
answer your question or reasonably I was
just curious to hear your thoughts
thank you just join us and if both
devices are certainly you may produce
the identity state which is
unfortunately very experimentally
realistic then would your fidel F max
quantity I guess you call it F max in
the Baber would that say you passed the
test you bought you get a fidelity of 1
yes if yeah if you're both completely
wrong when do you get one yeah that's
true yeah but you would of course and
people obvious as a by-product for
example see the purity of these
individual devices and if so we gain a
little bit more information and just
saying one we also see that there's no
purity and you wouldn't be of course
concluding that story both machines are
wrong I guess thank you
okay just one country
Lyde and how we can could measure this
thing of course we put establish a
quantum link between these two quantum
machine and just try to teleport one
state to the other and look at it and
perform this measurement locally and
these local overlap measurements of two
quantum states to many-body quantum
state has been demonstrated as saying
before our problem that this kind of
version and how could one measure this
is of course that is kind of quantum
link at least from anybody many body
systems does not from anybody wants it
does not really exist and so option two
and only the other side at the end of
the possibilities would basically be
let's just perform tomography and both
devices communicate the results and just
compute the fidelity but that's of
course exponentially inefficient and
maybe I was not the most clever or
optimal solution and so we kind of
thinking how can we do this and they
thought quantum link but a bit more
efficient at it is somewhat more
efficient than for tomography and at
least you use exactly again this
randomized measurements in the in a very
similar way as we described them before
so you you do a quantum state you
prepare the quantum state you apply a
set of random unitary state and then
measure it and what what one gets all
this of course from the statistics of
these probabilities together purity and
you can do and platform - of course the
same thing we get also the purity and
now if you now really use this uses now
the same random unitary and both devices
then of course you can also cross
correlate the probability probabilities
and what you find is exactly by very
simple generalization of the formula to
be sending before but just the cross
correlation of the covariance of these
probabilities and matches to the the
trace product of these two states
exactly so in this way you have all the
ingredients need for this basha
modalities and importantly involves only
classic communications of of such kind
of local local measurements and both
devices so we do just local operations
local local measurements and diffic
crucial kind of assumption or
we need to guarantee that you have
prepared the same many militaries in
both devices of course the course of
questions again how many do we need now
in the end of his measurements and there
we have two parameters at hand here
first of all this first look to estimate
this probabilities so we have number of
measurements per unitary and then we
have a second one we have the one
tractor estimate this is humble average
so we have a number of a bunch of friend
militaries and it's the magic the
product of these two will give you the
total number of measurements and so
what's plotted here it's the total
number of measurements and as a function
of a total number of measurements to
obtain this this fidelity of marks which
I've been defining before up to up to
fixed statistical error and as a
functional and I've got it here is
number of measurements you need to do it
to get it up to a fixed sophistic arrow
up to a subsystem size to and as a
function of U sub system size and what
you can see here is of course that the
logarithmic scales again that this is
kind of an exponential growth here for
example if you focus you in the product
state and you find you find an
exponential but if you look at these
exponents which which come out here from
these numerical calculations and that
you that you actually find that these
exponents are below one so there again
if you could at least if compared to
full condensate more graffiti
quite quite friendly so it's again this
kind of regime of 10 to 20 may 10 to 20
cubits where this kind of method would
be applicable and supportin again that
is just the subsystem size is appearing
so you could okay in this kind of
machine these methods I and again that
kind of exactly this regime there is
today for example e6 experimenting in
this book was done and so I'll show you
that's again some experimental results
if at the moment not to quantum quantum
machines which we would be but you can
compare a present but what we have is an
experiment it's exactly what this
experiment I've been describing before
so
quench dynamics experiments start with
his more simple initial state perform a
dynamics if in interacting in
Hamiltonian and get some an experimental
state out and now we can of course go
and also simulate this experiment on the
theory and and therefore and apply on
the theoretical state the same random
unit Aries and then also an estimate or
calculate these probabilities exactly
just not for your computer I mean when
we can cross correlate theory in
experiment in precisely the form I've
been describing before and the result
what comes out there is plotted here so
what's what's shown here is is fidelity
and as again as a fact for various
subsystems again as a function of a
subsystem size so one would be just one
iron 2 would be 1 and 2 I 10 would be
before 10 9 system fidelity so we reduce
density matrix but in this case the full
density matrix for 10 irons in this
setting so what you can see here is that
individual subsystems small subsets in
match very well with between theory and
experiment then but if you went increase
and of course we see a slight drop you
see a drop up to the foot and iron
fidelity and also you see a drop if you
increase this time after which the
fidelity is measured within fear in
experiments different colors are getting
different times but so for a full 10
iron system you see that present
compared to their minimal value which
would be 1 divided by its best mention
here you find really quite a high
fidelity it still up here despite this
status as I've been showing before
really a complex stage is a lot of
intelligent and so this kind of shows
yes I'm sorry
yeah just actually just want to follow
up on something that Robin asked so it
seems like for this you know validation
with theory you it seems like that you
most care about is the the overlap of
the entire 10 cubits with what's
predicted by theory yes is there reason
to look at Fidelity's of subsystems is
that interest
an intrinsic reason I think it tells you
for example it tells you something I'm
come to it in also next it tells you a
little bit how arrows increase if you if
you look at more system so if you have
if it's a simple state and you see about
the case you know something about for
example how large are errors on a single
qubit level for example and you just
extrapolate back and you can see see set
of some certain the quality of certain
operations just by by extrapolating back
for example and looking how they decayed
your system size and so I think in this
sense is it's it's meaningful to look at
at subsystem and then of course I've
been showing now before but this is a
more general and I think a bit up
crashing of amuse well how much can you
learn actually if you just if you would
have in a larger quantum system you
might have only access to subsistence
abilities how much can you learn now
about the global fatalities from just
looking at for example of all possible
subsystems in the system of all possible
subsystems in the system not necessary
one but up to a given size only I think
one that's clips I'm not sure the
information in there but it's a question
soon yeah bit a no question of how much
money can learn in detail from this but
certainly in situations where you
understand something about what you
intend this kind of decay tells you how
how good your operations are in see
thanks yeah this is exactly one point
and I wanted to speak now also about it
with a possible imperfection which could
spoil this is this comparison based in
this method and one one of them is of
course I've been saying you need to do
the same random unitary in both machines
so what could happen this you cannot do
this or you cannot yeah you just have a
mismatch miss collaboration between the
experiment or the experiments and the
theory
so we'd have some unitary error and if
you have such kind of unitary error we
looked at the what what happens is that
this effect is the estimation of this
nominator and typically about it but
what happens is that this nominate is
actually decreased by such kind of
systematic math major and I think that
that's one of the main reason that you
see this drop or already here in this
earlier thing we haven't you have a
mismatch between we appliqué the unitary
switch we apply an experiment and the
ones we apply on a theory computer and
the how large this mismatch is here we
can actually tell from from how it
decays their system size and the second
thing is what can happen is of course
the coherence acting during this random
interest and we can and there's a final
detection fidelity and and all of this
can be model again it's the SD coherence
and this effects now both over that
estimation and purity and but in total
of what the body leads to is that this
fidelity is typically also decreased and
by this type of errors so if you have
such kind of possible imperfection at
least in perturbation theory one can
show that this is only to a drop of your
estimated fidelity or not false
positives and you also try to
characterize this experimentally by just
preparing an initial product state in
the system and we look at it is a theory
experiment fidelity and we estimate this
fidelity in two ways so in the first way
we just apply a single random unitary I
mean just a standard way in a second
ready
artificially or what we did in the
experiment was done that they apply
artificially to concatenated twenty
meters so it's still a brand new
military's but it's just two of them and
what you can see here then is for
example that it's again that's a fury
experiment fidelity as a function of
sustenance but this actually the
concatenated one decays much faster and
then one with just a single this just
tells you that of course this unitary
arrows and automatic coherence they add
up if you trust to double or amount of
unitary and that's why it decays you
first and from this how much the
difference here is you can actually see
in
tell us something about the quality of
this single qubit operations
undress another question um is there
error also in the application of the
random unit Aries in the measurement yes
exactly that's that's an answer
yeah precisely okay all right thank you
and we want to wrap up in a few minutes
so there's some further questions at the
end
yeah yeah yeah I come to my and yeah
last item this topic so you can also see
the last thing which we tried Wendy you
don't have to experiments but what you
can do is of course take the same
experiment and correlated with itself
and that's exactly what's plotted here
so we divide the experimental data into
two parts one taking a day one second a
day - and you correlate the
experimenters itself and look at the
fidelity of the experiment itself and
that's exactly what's brought it here at
initial time so no time evolution in
this question that makes just the
initial time and you see the the orange
line is the fidelity of the experiment
to itself again as a function of
subsistence size and what you can see
the experiment matches actually quite
good itself in particular is made it's
much better than when it would match to
theory and so this is theory experiment
of the same state and that's precisely
this mission edge between theory and
experiment you have here which can that
can lead to further decay in the random
unit area so it doesn't mean that the
actual state do not match but it's just
a measurement procedure and can't tell
you because there's a D correlations
between the units so it was it tells you
that you that you should yeah one
function we they have good single qubit
operations here there's a more basic -
also for at a later time at one exactly
okay
yeah and you can you can actually play
this game a little bit further and not
only look at it it's quantum states
which are the same but you can also look
at at quantum states which are not
supposed to be the same and and and
start studying many-body quantum
dynamics in these systems for example
you can look at fidelities of quantum
states which evolved to different times
and took a fidelity is decay with
different time evolution and so on but
better maybe a topic too much detail
here anymore yeah I just wanted to say
there's a question in the question and
answer question box Richard I could
actually unmute you and you can ask it
Richard do you want to ask yeah but we
can wait to the end of the talk okay I
was anticipating the question session
already okay yeah so let me maybe this
is one in one slightly explain what what
you had in mind for the auto talks and
so and the the measurement of auto talks
is is following path you you would like
to measure a correlation function in an
experiment which is of the following
type you have an operator V and you have
an operator W of T at a lifetime in
Heisenberg picture and then you have an
operator V at at some time and operator
W of T of another time and you would
like to measure this type of correlation
functions and by and that's typically a
very hard correlation function between
you have such kind of operators at
different times
and you typically what you would need to
do in the experiment you would need to
evolve a experiment forward and backward
in time and that's a difficult task to
do and so what if all of this is this
particular type of correlation functions
and you can actually go and measure this
type of correlation function again this
least randomized measurements and by
just applying random unitary seen to
experiments evolve and just evolve so
what you do is in one experiment you
apply a random military to initial state
you board forward in time and to measure
its operator W at a certain time so get
a certain correlation function and in a
second experiment you again do this but
you in addition you're apply this
operator V and you
just evolved forward in time this
experiment and when you cross-correlate
is to experiment and what you are
defined from these cross correlations
again this is very non-trivial
correlations function that you have here
which involves this operators at
different times and that's kind of the
general idea of this is randomized
measurements which can be applied in
very different settings and it's I think
I'm already at the end of my time so I
would skip and what he says but if
you're interested in here you've just
recently been looking at at this type of
correlation Francis also an experiment
and found how how the osaki actually
behaves in this we strapped in
experiments early F is non-trivial
dynamics of long range is in tight
dynamics so v I'm at the end of my talk
and which has to wrap up and saying that
we randomized measurements are really
nice to probe in verify quantum states
beyond standard observables and they
vary in this way I very nicely
applicable in our kind of
state-of-the-art quantum simulators if
there you have such single side and
control in video and importantly what
I've not been talking so much about is
that all these local and military
operations
you can also replies by replaced by
multi qubit and random unitary and from
which you can generate by by by clifford
gates for example if you just interested
in a to design or you can also do it by
a time evolution in quantum simulation
experiments and this gives you sometimes
inventions in statistics but it does
cause a higher and experimental and
complexity yeah and this is I'm at the
end of my talk and I would like to thank
you very much for you and for your
attention
okay thank you undress so I will unmute
loops unmute Richard do you want to ask
your question Richard yeah hi I'm just a
very very nice talk thank you very much
I have a practical question like on one
slide you said that you had a certain
budget on allocating samples across
different unitary bases and like
sample repetitions I think it was like
you you mentioned they did it 500 random
unit Aries and a hundred fifty samples
per annum unitary yeah exactly
can you elaborate a bit about why this
is a good choice like how do you know
how to budget your resources they
basically it was by a backward search we
just looked at where we get the best the
smallest statistical error it's kind of
a rule of thumb bits that you what you
if your state is very mixed or very
entangled you you expect that then it's
very soft sufficient to use less random
unit Ares because the fluctuations over
over unit Ares are just smaller if your
states mixed but in general it's it's
it's it's real optimization question we
don't even understand okay
thank you very much all right any other
questions
undress I have a quick question this is
Robin again thank you for a lovely talk
- I'd like to try and get a sort of
physicist back-of-the-envelope idea of
resource cost here and if you've thought
about the following question suppose
that for your cross-platform
verification imagine that Google had two
of their Sycamore devices with you know
fifty three hundred broken in the same
way so they both have 53 qubits not 54
and they wanted to demonstrate using
your protocol the same thing that they
demonstrated in their nature paper last
year which is that they had produced a
particular desired state with 0.2%
fidelity but instead they wanted to show
that both of their devices had produced
states there are two devices had Berdoo
states that had point two percent
fidelity with each other could you give
me an idea of the number of you know the
resources required to do that using your
protocol and whether it would be easier
than ten thousand years or two days on a
supercomputer
so I think if you would like to estimate
a full 53 like the full state fidelity
that's not something which really
accessible so I can't even give you an
so typically what you have is that
number of measurements approximately
schedule astute away and basically to
today so the exponents one before the
end or slightly below one so yeah so
that's kind of the order
so order of magnitude the resource
expensiveness sort of scales roughly the
same as the best classical simulation
fidelity estimation yes
importantly of course what you could do
and that's you could just look at all
possible sub system a few up to a given
size and learn something about this in
this sense about how good we up to a
certain level of correlation depth if
you would like to find formulated in you
say of quotations you even know that
maybe up to a certain n body
correlations which which is the size of
a subsystem you are bidding to access
they're getting to spend thank you all
right we have a question from one so I
have so I see like all this exponential
floating around in the estimators right
like but this is very generic so meaning
that this applies to any program say so
if you assume something about the
quantum states like for instance this
matrix products state and so on so can
you do yeah it's a very interesting
question I think that's something you
would like to yeah it was me asking I
would like to work on in the future at
the moment the protocol is state
agnostic yeah and it and even it even
tries to randomize and states I so and
at the moment very it's it's not
incorporated that you can do better for
a certain state but that's definitely
something we would like to look at
Thanks
alright well let's think Andres again
alright and we'll convene around one for
the next talk